okay if you had to guess what type of
local business we are at welcome to pop
to take a look at the local business
here this gourmet popcorn business a
perfect treat for the holidays popped
has always had a storefront but within
the last couple of years their online
business has taken over and with
yesterday being Black Friday and today
being shop local Saturday the orders
have been coming in with December being
their busiest month
going into December we get really really
busy with online orders and we ship
throughout the the entire country where
we're like well should we just stop the
retail and just do an online business
because you know Chris it's it's so
great overall
um you know it's it we feel we we feel
like it's important to have a storefront
here in Las Vegas
and the owner shares they have sent out
hundreds of orders within the
expectation to surpass a thousand within
the next couple of days now you can see
we're taking a live look at all of the
popcorn that they have to offer
currently the popcorn that I am munching
on is s'mores this is really good our
producer even said what did she say
cinnamon and sugar get toasted that's
one of her favorites so one of the top
three we got peppermint we've got
chocolate and what was the last one
caramel for the holiday season I'm going
to send it back to you Sasha